[Music]
Ricki over the years you have often
shown a fondness for taking kind of
embarrassing unflattering let's say
unflattering pictures of yourself and
then tweeting them out there and you go
out of your way to make yourself look as
strange and sometimes unpleasant as
possible I've done it with me
yeah we've we've you've been on the show
and you've taken almost every time you
take a weird picture with me and then
you get it out there yeah and I got a
head start on me I have to really try to
look weird we're out of time but do you
you're very talented at this and your
latest is what taking pictures of
yourself in the back of update of up the
ante
yeah no because in the path of Bath is
good because you have to get down there
and also the water distorts a little bit
and the the only problem is about you've
got to be careful you don't drop your
phone in it but you know I've had some
success there you think you so we have I
think I don't know how many of these we
have but let's just take a look at one
right now this is one that's that's my
sweetie this one here's your Viking hat
yeah yes it's a fantastic pick think of
that running out you a thousand
that's so threatening with the bubbles
what else is there another is that it oh
my god
I don't know how many percent I was know
away Norway horrifying you've got to
stop doing that I think I've got a gift
yeah oh yes you do and these are real
yeah they're real though yeah yes well I
knew you're gonna show those because
they had to ask my permission yeah yeah
but I had a little chat with your
producers and I thought I could do a
bath pic here you you want to do a
better perfect live bath bit yeah
oh so you're gonna do one yeah but I
want you to do one too
[Applause]
isn't this dog five or four people just
cut fired here wait so what you are you
went you would you seriously want it
let's get anyway take a picture and and
which we yeah yeah
wait so I don't is it warm enough let me
get rid of the microphone all right so
we're just gonna get it this is gonna
ruin the suit but we're just go
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
yeah show it turn that around
[Music]
that's that's fantastic can we get a
shot
[Applause]
we're more